[موسيقى]
هذا صحيح ، لكن
هذا لا يتعلق بفرقة KitKat نفسها ، إنها
قصة عن جلجل كيك هيد وكيف
لم يكن من المفترض أبدًا أن توجد ،
اسمي مايكل ليفين ، أنا ملحن
وكاتب أغاني لدي  كنت أكتب الأغاني منذ
56 عامًا حتى
الآن ، فقد سجلت عرضًا يسمى الحالة الباردة ، لقد كتبت
أغنية جلجل لـ kool-aid والتي استمرت
لسنوات عديدة ولكن ما يعرفه الجميع هو
KitKat gimme gimme a break jingle. تلقيت
مكالمة من وكالة تتعامل مع حساب KitKat
هم  كان لديهم حملة
أحبوها بالفعل وكانوا بحاجة فقط إلى أغنية مبعثرة
ليقولها العميل لا ،
لا يمكنك تقديم
فكرة واحدة لعميلك ، يجب أن يكون لديك شيء
سيشتريه وشيء يمكنه
التخلص منه لذلك هذا  كانت الأغنية المنبثقة التي
جئت إلى اجتماع مع كين
شولمان الذي كان كاتب
الوكالة وأعطاني بضع أوراق
من الأفكار الغنائية المحتملة
واتفقنا على استراحة أعطني استراحة كسر
قطعة من شريط KitKat  ركبت
المصعد  في الطابق الثالث وبحلول
الوقت الذي وصلت فيه إلى الطابق الأول ،
كان لديّ ميزانية صغيرة جدًا
لكل شيء لم أكن أستطيع تحمله حرفيًا
لتوظيف المطربين ، لذلك عندما ذهبنا
للقيام بالإعلان التجاري الفعلي ، قال كريس المنتج
جيدًا لماذا لا  لدينا الفرقة
تغنيها ، لقد
قمنا بعمل Volcom في لقطة واحدة
والأداة أيضًا في لقطة واحدة ولكن على
جسر الأغنية التي ذهبت في الأصل ،
يمكنك الاحتفاظ بها لنفسك من خلال de wood
وأن تكون عادلاً لأن طعم الطباشير المقرمش
هو  أحببت في كل مكان كان صوتًا واحدًا
يغني ، وانتهى بي الأمر إلى
أن أكون المغني الرئيسي ونتيجة لذلك في
تلك المرحلة ، وضعت الوكالة كلتا الحملتين
مع جمهور اختبار ومنحتني استراحة
انتهى بها الأمر إلى أن أكون مفضلاً كثيرًا من قبل الأشخاص الذين
قاموا بعمل جيد جدًا.  لم
أصدق النتائج تمامًا ، لذا اختبروها مرة أخرى
وكان أداءها أفضل في تلك المرحلة ،
وقرروا مواكبة الأمر.كنت سعيدًا لأنهم
اختاروها لم يكن لدي أدنى فكرة
أنه سيظل هنا بعد ثلاثين عامًا.
أخبرتها بأنها  لقد اضطررت إلى
بناء مصنع KitKat جديد
لتلبية الطلب على مر السنين حيث
أصبح جزءًا من
العقل الباطن الأمريكي وأنا فخور بأنني
ساهمت في ذلك وأنا سعيد
بكل الإصدارات الجديدة التي تخرج في
الغالب من الناس.  حول هذا الأمر ،
إنهم مثل ، هيا ، أعطني مايكل
فترة راحة ، يعتقد الجميع تقريبًا
أنهم أذكياء حقًا عندما طلبوا مني
أن أعطيهم خبزًا